qué significa para la iglesia
nicaragüense este pronunciamiento del
papá francisco porque si pide diálogo
pero no se refiere por ejemplo
directamente a todo lo que está
ocurriendo
y yo en ese sentido quisiera ser
bastante directo y manifestar mi
decepción en relación a lo manifestado
por francisco en la iglesia católica en
nicaragua está viviendo la mayor
persecución en su historia en este
momento hay nueve sacerdotes privados de
la libertad de su libertad de manera
arbitraria incluyendo al obispo álvarez
una de las voces más potentes en
nicaragua y una de las voces más
legítimas que continuaba demandando es
justicia para las decenas de víctimas de
2018 de tal manera que lo que ha dicho
el papá francisco sin mencionar siquiera
a la iglesia católica porque no menciona
habla de personas y de instituciones en
este sentido destacar en nicaragua no
hay instituciones lo que existe es una
de las dictaduras en este momento más
feroces de américa latina que ha sido
implacable contra líder religioso contra
periodistas e incluso contra artistas
decenas de ellos han sido obligadas a
desplazarse de manera forzada a otros
países y otros han sido expulsados
dejándolos en una en una condición de
apatridia es decir vivimos una situación
siempre de la historia de nicaragua y el
papá francisco se ha quedado corto bueno
y porque las palabras del pontífice
llegan en este momento sabemos que el
papá francisco es un jefe de estado pero
pues es un líder seguido por millones de
personas se puede considerar demorada o
tardía esta reacción
absolutamente tardía la represión y
nicaragua se ha agudizado en la última
semana pero desde 2018 vivimos un estado
policial una represión como política de
estado una impunidad total como política
de estado y un verdadero terrorismo de
estado de tal manera que el papá se ha
quedado
rezagado en ese sentido recordemos que
hace dos meses fue expulsado de
nicaragua el nuncio apostólico y los
ataques contra la iglesia no son de
ahorita es decir desde hace meses y años
la iglesia católica ha venido viviendo
una suerte de sistemática persecución y
que las últimas semanas como dije
anteriormente se ha grabado totalmente
hablando en términos prácticos qué
efectos puede generar este llamado que
hace el papá daniel ortega lo va a
escuchar
daniel ortega se caracteriza en esta
última etapa por no escuchar a nadie es
decir no escucha a los mecanismos de
protección ni de naciones unidas ni del
sistema interamericano y hoy que el papá
se ha pronunciado hace una hora es decir
en este momento están siendo asediada
iglesias en el norte del país en
matagalpa y también en más allá en el
departamento de masaya es decir lo que
te indica es que ortega no está
escuchando
ortega lo que está haciendo es y
recetando como decimos y nicaragua
represión como el único camino para
mantenerse en el poder en ese sentido el
planteamiento de diálogo y convivencia
de del papá francisco no cabe es decir
en una práctica de estado caracterizada
por la represión y la violencia